- If you don't stand for something,
in this industry,
you will for everything
and you will not be
compensated on the way down.
And if you believe every
negative thing about you,
you're not going to get out of bed.
One bad thing does not define who I am.
I am so much more than a failed TV show.
- She began her career in the 1990's
appearing on television sitcoms.
Her breakthrough role was in a
teen comedy film Bring It On.
She stars as the lead character
in the drama series Being Mary Jane.
She's Gabrielle Union
and here's my take on her
Top 10 Rules of Success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- So then I go to the Essence Awards
the day after the event that you had.
We've all been to the
Essence Awards and you spoke
and as you started to speak,
you were getting the
Fierce and Fearless Award.
Obviously, you had given
that a lot of thought.
And as you started to speak,
my own mouth dropped and
then it got wider and wider.
By the time you finished we were all like,
whoa, what was that?
(applause)
- We live in a town
that rewards pretending.
And I had been pretending
to be fierce and fearless
for a very long time.
I was a victim masquerading as a survivor.
I used to revel in
gossip and rumors and the
and I lived for the negativity inflicted
upon my sister actresses or anyone
who I felt whose shine diminished my own.
Fortunate enough to be honored
at the Essence Awards Luncheon
for the Fierce and Fearless Award.
I was talking to my girlfriend,
A.J. Johnson who's my trainer
but she's also like a life coach,
and I was like, do I tell it?
I mean if I'm getting an award
for being Fierce and Fearless,
how about if I really
be fierce and fearless
and explain to people my evolution.
I love who I am today,
but that wasn't always the case.
I didn't love my features.
I didn't love my weight.
I didn't my hair.
I didn't love my lips.
And it's been an evolution
and I wasn't always nice
or as gracious as I could have been
or happy for other people.
And just sort of explain that journey
through my speech.
It had been such a long
journey to get to that point.
And I started doing the work on myself
and really wanting to be the woman
I always sort of dreamed I wanted to be,
but when I got divorced and
I had a career set-back,
I had hit basically, rock-bottom.
I had reached out to A.J. Johnson
and we started doing the work,
and being honest and
really, really looking
at myself and my life, and my choices.
- So A.J. Johnson was a coach?
- [Gabrielle] Is my, yeah like
she was a physical trainer
but also like a life coach.
And she was like let's really, you ready?
I don't think you're ready.
I don't really think you're ready
to really look at your
life and your choices,
I think you like how you live.
I think you think it's cute.
I think you think, I
make a living doing this,
I make a lot of money doing this
so why should I change.
And I was like, true.
So I had to really examine
all the choices I've made
as an adult and what I
like and what I don't like,
and there was a lot I didn't like.
So from that point on
in like my early 30's,
I started really living my truth
and my words matched my actions.
So when I was putting together a speech
about Fierce and Fearless,
I was like, A.J. do I tell it?
Do I really tell people
what this journey has been?
Because you know people,
they see you on a red carpet
or they see you in a
picture or in an interview,
and they're like, oh she must
be extra perfect or whatever.
- People have their
perceptions of what they think
your life is like.
- Absolutely.
- And it's been the absolute opposite.
Going through,
going from sexual assault
victim to rape survivor,
going through a divorce,
having career set-backs,
re-examining why you even
are in this business.
Who am I?
Who do I want to be to the world?
That's what we were like,
let's just tell it.
- Yeah.
Let the chips fall where they may!
And I never thought that being honest
would have that kind of reaction.
- Gab, I know you had some
issues when coming back
for this new season of Being Mary Jane.
And as a woman, as an actress,
as a director, can we
talk about equal pay?
'Cause I know it something
to do with equal pay.
I don't know the details
when it came to your battle with BET,
and everything that happened.
- Well it actually didn't
which was interesting that,
but I'm happy to tackle gender equity
when it comes to my financial statements.
We're doing the same amount of work
and if my star and your
star is in the same place,
and I bring to the table
the exact same thing
you bring to the table, we
should be paid the exact same.
It's not like I'm only
on a couple episodes
or I'm only working 15 minutes
and you're there everyday all day,
that's something different.
But if we're doing the same job
and we're bringing the
same thing to the table,
give me my money,
give me the same thing
that you're giving him.
I will go, I would rather
use all of my money
towards lawsuits for pay equity.
But at the end of the day,
if you don't stand up for something,
in this industry,
you will fall for everything
and you will not be
compensated on the way down.
So that is my overall message.
If there's something that
you find that is unequitable,
unfair, it's up to you.
No one's going to fight your battles.
If they can save money
not paying you--
- Oh, they will.
they will.
So you have to be your biggest,
your own biggest and best advocate.
- But speaking of fighting
for what you believe is right,
how many times, coming up in your career,
did it backfire on you?
Did you decide to put your foot down?
And they'll be like all
right, then we don't need you.
- Never.
- 'Cause I sometimes believe
that a lot of women get scared.
You know what I mean?
- A lot of us get scared.
- There were times I just didn't do it
so that's different then doing it
and it blowing up in my face.
Never ever have I opened
my mouth to speak out
against some kind of injustice at work
whether that be something sexist,
something racist, something misogynistic,
something just flat-out wack or unfair
where it ever came back negatively,
and affected my opportunities.
If anything, people
have more respect for me
and like having me around
'cause they'd rather me speak
up than them half the time.
I don't ever shy away from that.
- How do you deal with feedback?
Criticism?
Positive or negative?
- You take it all with a grain of salt.
I mean early in my career,
I was named the next It girl,
and you're like,
well I think I should really believe this.
And then you read, you're
the worst thing ever,
you should never leave the house.
And you're like, oh we
should throw that out.
Eventually, you just
kind of get to a place
where they kind of cancel each other out.
You're going to hear the naysayers
and the people who think you suck
and then there are going to be the people
who think you're the
Second Coming of Pockets.
It's usually somewhere in the middle.
(audience laughs)
If you believe all your praise,
there's no where to go,
you're not going to grow.
And if you believe every
negative thing about you,
you're not going to get out of bed.
So I try to be reasonable,
people whose opinion I respect, I listen.
Like when Regina King,
she directs four episodes
this season of Being Mary Jane
and she's a good friend,
but she never let me slide.
We shoot a lot, we shoot
almost 10 pages a day
which is sort of unheard of in television.
You can get a little lazy, to be honest.
And she would never let me be lazy,
she'll be like, G?
Come on now, come on now.
(growls)
So it's nice to have people
who will call you on your shit,
and can we say shit on?
It's the internet.
- We're grownups, come on.
- Well if my lip can be
sweaty, I can say shit.
Who will call you on your shit
and make you accountable
and make you better.
And that's huge.
If I could leave you with anything,
is you have to value yourself.
And it sounds so super
cliche and everybody says it,
and if you don't value yourself,
you don't love yourself,
no one's going to love you.
But seriously, I just realized that at,
I got divorced, my show got canceled.
Had all these terrible things
happen and I hit rock-bottom.
What I realized is I'm
an educated, amazing,
vibrant, relevant person.
One bad thing does not define who I am.
I am so much more than a failed TV show
or a failed marriage
or what the blogs say,
I'm so much more than that.
- Most significant skill set
or characteristic you
developed as an athlete
that has enabled you to be
successful in your career?
- Leadership, absolutely.
There's something about
being able to direct
the action on the court
that informs your personality.
I took away different skills
just from working with the group of women,
leading a group of women,
trying to form an identity for our team.
And that identity, above everything else,
was be your own leader,
resilience and stick together.
- [Interviewer] And what my platform is
learning to love yourself.
So could you tell me a little
bit about any insecurities
you may have had and how you
learned to overcome them?
- I think I can tell you
insecurities I didn't have.
Everything.
I mean growing up as the
darkest girl in my family,
growing up super thin,
not having secondary
sexual characteristics
come in until much later,
being the only black girl
in all-white communities.
I could go on and on, and on.
Like literally feeling like I shrink
when a beautiful woman walks in.
All of that.
It's been a journey.
You have to make a
commitment to wanting better
than functioning in dysfunction.
I'm those black people
that you meet in life
where if someone says,
I'm not a racist, I've got a black friend,
I would've been that black friend.
(audience laughs)
Assimilation was complete.
Along with being the chip in the cookie
at a very young age,
came the advice from my parents,
which I think a lot of our parents
in this room have probably given us,
you are going to have to
be bigger, badder, better
just to be considered equal.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Which is very accurate.
But what it does to the
self-esteem of a small child
is to say that,
you are always going
to not be good enough.
So in school, I would
try to do this to my lips
so I wouldn't have big lips,
didn't want to be too black,
had to make sure that I always got those,
you're so articulate compliments,
which by the way,
if you ever say that to an adult,
it's actually not a compliment.
(audience chuckles)
I wanted to make sure
my hair was so straight.
I used to leave relaxers
on my hair so long,
I would get lesions
because I wanted to fit in.
I wanted to be good enough.
I didn't want to be a joke.
I didn't want to be a loser.
Anytime some guy did not return my love,
it was because I'm not good enough
because I'm a joke, I'm a loser.
When I got raped at 19
at my after-school job,
it wasn't just some awful coincidence,
some terrible freak accident.
It wasn't an unspeakable crime,
it was because I was a joke and a loser,
and this is what happens.
When I got divorced,
I'm a joke and a loser, of course.
Show gets canceled, joke
and a loser of course.
And on that day in August,
when I started doing the work,
they were like, you got to replace that
that voice in your head
that's telling you you're
a joke and a loser.
You got to stop being crippled by a fear
of possible humiliation.
That little voice that pops
up in your head that says,
don't raise your hand,
you're not going to
answer the question right.
Don't put that on, you're too big.
Don't wear your hair
like that, it's so ugly.
Nothing in my closet works.
I'm so dumb, I can't do it.
No one's going to love me.
Why is my pain meek?
Replace that.
And it sounded so cliche and so easy.
That day I decided to stop telling myself
that I was a joke and a loser,
that I was dope and fly, and the reason...
What sports taught me is
how to work within a group
and how to find strength in a team.
Same with after-school activities,
I was in the Spanish club.
(laughs)
(speaking Spanish)
- [Man] Oh really?
(audience laughs)
- It had helped to have
strength in numbers
and know how to function within a group
because in life, you're not an island.
You're not by yourself
even though sometimes it feels like it,
you need to know how
to work within a group
and how to pull different
your positive attributes,
so we can be a strong unit.
But when you are looking to
find other people in life
that will help you be successful
and keep you on the right path,
it's that team mentality of,
okay you're better at this than I am,
you're better at,
you know my girl Dawn,
she's a marketing guru,
so we all go to Dawn when we need help
in terms of how best to market ourselves
'cause a lot of us are unemployed.
A lot of my friends lost their jobs
so we're like how do we to
Dawn to help her, help us?
Utilizing her skills that can enable us
to become better people.
I live for the quiet moments
where I can be my most authentic self
and hear myself think.
Somebody asked me, what makes you happy?
My husband said, bacon.
(audience laughs)
Which is true.
But I'm happiest when I'm
at my most authentic self.
When nobody's looking,
when nobody's judging me,
when nobody's leaving nasty
comments on my social media.
And I can just exist.
And in that quiet space I realized
I am worthy by birthright.
I am fierce and fabulous
because I breathe.
All of us here in this room,
we are worthy, we are valid.
Our journeys are real and worthwhile.
And there's nothing that anyone can do
to take that away from us.
Everything terrible
that has happened to us,
we have a choice in how we ought to react.
A lot of times what we're
actually reacting to,
is the fear of humiliation,
the fear of, what are they
going to think about me?
The fear of possible judgment.
Newsflash, people will judge you
whether you discovered the cure for cancer
or sit on the couch.
You might as well live.
I am a wife
but that does not define me.
I'm an actress and that sure
as hell, does not define me.
I'm a parent while awesome,
that is not my whole life.
None of those things
even though I get a lot of
praise for that, makes me worthy.
I am worthy by birthright.
I am Gabrielle Union-Wade.
(audience applauds)
(school bell rings)
(chuckles)
- Good morning Saugerties High!
Hope you're having a
super-duper day so far.
This is Principal Davidson.
- And I'm Vice Principal Cook.
And it's time for the
morning announcement.
Attention sophomores!
The field trip to the Natural
History Museum is this Friday.
And the only student who hasn't paid yet,
surprise, surprise,
is Mitchell Henderson.
- Come on, Mitch!
- So on Friday,
(acoustic "Bitch Better
Have My Money" by Rihanna)
♫ Mitch better have my money
♫ Wants to come wid' us
♫ Or we won't get on that bus
♫ Don't act like you forgot
♫ Just step, stop, stop
- Okay hey oh, oh!
- Stop it!
- All right, all right.
Hey Mitch you heard?
- Pay me what you owe me, Mitch!
- Okay, all right.
Don't let me catch you slippin', Mitch!
- Okay, all right now.
Come on.
- Oh gosh.
- Come on.
- Oh, it got away from me, didn't it?
- It did a little.
- Oh gosh.
- That song does that to people.
That's my favorite song by Rye-Hana.
- Yeah she's good, she's good.
And lastly, here we come
down the home stretch
of the announcements.
- Oh giddyup!
(laughs)
Giddyup.
- It has come to our
attention that some students
have been playing hooky
and skipping class.
And I just (gasps) I just
want to remind those students
that we don't take these actions lightly.
In fact,
(acoustic "Watch Me
Whip/Nae-Nae" by Silento)
♫ If you skip
♫ Then I'll go cray cray
♫ If you skip, skip
♫ Ooh watch me, watch me
♫ I go cray cray
♫ I'll go, I'll go cray cray
Have a great day Saugerties High!
(audience applauds)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Neo asked me to.
Also if you want to nominate someone
for the next Top 10 video,
please check the description
for a link-to video
where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned?
That blew your mind?
That you're going to
immediately apply to your life
or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Jane Cassell.
Jane, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking that picture,
and posting it on LinkedIn.
I really, really appreciate the support.
I hope you're enjoying the
read and the wine as well.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.